we're gonna have to push up go for a
steal
Harris spritz away mr. bell rebound
Simmons backs it out to be the heater
gonna have to foul down by two with
eight seconds left for three
[Applause]
a fling to put Miami up by one with 6.9
seconds left
with six trade point
in the last forty nine seconds
this just ridiculous
what a defensive effort instead of
fouling they're disciplined enough to
form a trap watch Jimmy Butler
impressive here with his hands on the
reach right here pokes the ball out that
gives the heat the opportunity and then
just the confidence of the young men he
had the opening I can make buckets
I can make legends Schuyler here let's
go back to the defensive end though it
looked like they were gonna have to foul
but Butler steel set up heroes three and
now the final Ashe 6.9 seconds left
they eat need one more stop every player
140km last time they're in a one-point
game now 6.9 love it
he fumbles
[Applause]
and they will try to steal the game
Butler will get two free throws with 343
seconds left
incredible what a finish for Miami T its
just desire will Paul play they executed
they get it inside the fumble allows
Jimmy to go down and dirty and just so
strong with those hands pulled that away
snatched it away
back-to-back steals by one of the best
two-way players in the game he just
missed the front end that's a very big
menace remember the Sixers have no
timeouts left
let's go be quick
their position they need the rebound if
brother mentions it's good mentally 106
I gotta goes only to the court down to
the three-point we deploy in a
Richardson with to the exit soon gets it
all miss it but we get a foul
foul is called
[Applause]
social disorder as fully redeemed
Mitchell Irvin Lane
a controversial call there on Goren's
raga truth will be the first to get a
look at that what a wild frantic finish
Richardson with time winding down yes
dropping spinach it's a fair call there
that was a good call left arm
it's a shame Pam was right there to
court didn't need to go for that reach
[Music]
[Applause]
impact Jay rich even though he was
running alongside and as a tough gather
and shot with a 6-10 guy on your hip now
this should not be free you couldn't ask
for more drama
mr. just Richardson missed it
see if he tries to make this one Eric he
may try to miss it here that would be
the play and get the rebound gonna try
to miss it you've gotta block out
on the left water
or does it I did to hit the road if not
the room and
or maybe it's a lane violation on bed
seven
it looked like Simmons left prematurely
on the ball also has to hit the rim if
it hits the backboard it's a violation
it's meatball so they're gonna review
this again a lot of activity here Wow
I think is going to be a lane violation
on Ben Simmons let's look at it we're
sinners he's at the top of your screen
[Applause]
now did he leave before it left
Richardson's hands that is restitutive
to replace a tire and did it hit the rim
if it doesn't hit the rim it's a
violation that's it nothing room that's
heat ball
[Music]
so the freakshow did not hit the room so
that should be the heat basketball
second order look at us
[Music]
[Applause]
the backboard first it should be equal
I can't tell if it's glancing against
that rim there
I don't see it redirecting the ball
oh it did redirect a little bit market
ah I don't know our kids went off it
went off his hand awkward
I think it there get there good name
that did that is a good angle there guys
who could work in the truck
so now so then then it becomes more
about the lane violation to your point
[Applause]
they scored ethylic scored in time he's
see the nine tenths of a second still
left I hate to say this but I think
we're looking at a tie game in 108 right
now well there could be a lane violation
to the her if there's a lane violation
it would negate it would negate the
there's a lot going on here so again Ben
Simmons receipt goes over to early
before the ball leaves the hand of Jay
rich
[Applause]
well worst-case scenario will be tied
at1 away with nine tenths of a second